quiero mandar e imprimir un letrero para
el cumpleaños de mi mejor amiga pero en
el anuncio dice que el precio es por
metro cuadrado sabes que es un metro
cuadrado no te preocupes si no lo sabes
te voy a platicar lo que hice para pedir
el letrero del tamaño adecuado aunque
parece trabalenguas en realidad es muy
fácil un metro cuadrado
es un cuadrado que mide un metro por
cada lado recuerda que para calcular el
área de un cuadrado debemos multiplicar
lo que mide un lado por lo que mide el
otro aquí tenemos uno por uno y es igual
a 1 así que tenemos un metro cuadrado de
área b es muy fácil si queremos saber de
cuántos metros cuadrados era solo hay
que ver cuántos de esos cuadrados quiero
que quepan en mi letrero como es
alargado pongamos cuadros de manera
horizontal hasta que no se alcance el
texto el letrero dirá muchas felicidades
amiga parece que con cinco cuadros queda
muy bien así que debemos pedir los cinco
metros cuadrados porque mide cinco
metros de un lado y uno del otro
5 x 1 es igual a 5
pero pensándolo bien está muy grande y
no podría sostener lo vamos a intentar
con la mitad del tamaño actual así que
dejemos de largo en dos metros y medio y
ahora nuestro letrero es de dos y medio
pero necesitamos que esté menos alto
para que no quede tanto espacio vacío
hagámoslo de medio metro de alto es
decir la mitad queda perfecto en este
caso para saber cuántos metros cuadrados
me van a cobrar por el letrero vamos a
multiplicar 2.5 que es lo que mide de
largo por 0.5 de alto tenemos 1.25
metros cuadrados lo puedes observar al
juntar estas dos mitades de metro
cuadrado para formar uno y esta parte
que nos queda es un cuarto por eso son
1.25 metros cuadrados en estos casos
donde tenemos medidas de menos de un
metro te recomiendo utilizar otra unidad
de medida que es el 10 y metro cuadrado
al igual que el metro cuadrado donde si
metro cuadrado es un cuadrado que mide
un 10 y metro de cada lado y como
recuerdas un decímetro es una décima
parte de un metro
es decir el resultado de dividir un
metro en 10 partes y si comparamos un
metro cuadrado con un 10 y metro
cuadrado vemos que el decímetro cuadrado
es mucho más pequeño entonces si 10
decímetros hacen un metro con 5
decímetros tenemos medio metro eso es lo
que mide de alto nuestro letrero así que
será más fácil si usamos decímetros por
lo tanto mide 5 decímetros de alto por
25 10 y metros de largo
125 decímetros cuadrados si
multiplicamos 5 decímetros por 25
decímetros con estas medidas fui a la
imprenta y me pidieron que en una hoja
de papel les hicieron la muestra de cómo
quedaría el letrero es decir algo
pequeño para que ellos lo hicieran en
grande pero este letrero más pequeño no
es conveniente medirlo en decímetros
cuadrados así que te presento otra
unidad de medida el centímetro cuadrado
y como bien está suponiendo ocurre lo
mismo que con las anteriores 1
centímetro cuadrado es un cuadrado que
mide 1 centímetro por cada lado 1
centímetro es lo que resulta de dividir
un metro en 100 partes o 110 y metro en
10 partes por lo que 100 centímetros
equivalen a 10 decímetros o a un metro
si los ponemos juntos se verían más o
menos así el centímetro es muy pequeño
en comparación con el metro es por eso
que nos sirve para medir cosas pequeñas
juntos un metro cuadrado 110 y metro
cuadrado y 1 centímetro cuadrado se
verían más o menos así ya te pudiste dar
una idea de qué tipo de cosas podemos
medir con cada uno para el ejemplo que
nos piden vamos a tomar las medidas de
10 y metros y lo pasaremos a centímetros
nuestro rectángulo será de 25
centímetros por 5 centímetros y como
pasa con el letrero grande multiplicamos
25 centímetros por 5 centímetros para
obtener 125 centímetros cuadrados que
tiene nuestro ejemplo pequeño
así tendremos un rectángulo pequeño que
representa el grande que queremos
imprimir cuando lleve este ejemplo a la
imprenta sólo tendrán que agrandarlo 10
veces ya que un decímetro tiene 10
centímetros y así el letrero quedará muy
bien para sorprender a mi amiga hay
muchos otros objetos que podemos medir
para calcular el área en metros
decímetros y centímetros cuadrados con
tu regla mide todo lo que te rodea y
decide en qué unidad de medida es mejor
calcular el área dibuja un cuadrado de
un decímetros por un des y metro y
recorta lo para que compares la
superficie de varios objetos si tu
cuadro queda chico es porque será mejor
medir es objeto en metros cuadrados si
queda grande utiliza centímetros
cuadrados y si es adecuado medel en
decímetros para calcular su área en 10 y
metros cuadrados